bonsoir francesco rizzuto merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
les deux pays ont une relation très
amicale or c'est ce qu'a déclaré le
premier ministre boris johnson à bord de
l'avion qui l'emmenait à new york encore
des mots toujours des mots
qu'en est il vraiment
elle finit bien vendre des histoires
intéressantes
l'élan de la relation entre londres et
paris entre londres et bruxelles ne se
porte pas bien du tout une
juge utile oui il faut c'est une cliente
il se fait des rêves
ça veut dire quoi que la relation ne
cesse de se détériorer depuis le break
citant le divorce avec l'union
européenne autant de sujets
de divergence qui se multiplient
tout à fait aux
problèmes de droits de pêche dans la
manche qui est toujours en cours
l'un d'eux plus avons un problème avec
londres chris accusent paris
pas contrôler ses frontières afin que je
sorte que les gens franchissent
actuellement chanteuse
veut récupérer le contrôle de ses
frontières c'est qu'ils étaient serrés
cible et il y a le problème est
lié la france leurs élus qui serait le
passage de ce dernier donc je pense que
la situation ne pourrait pas l'être aux
pierres il ya également le problème de
l'irlande du nord
si l'union européenne a donné un peu de
mousse donc les relations ne se porte
pas bien franks a scoré d'auto
clairement cette affaire
deux sous-marins pour vous c'est une
illustration des conséquences du bric
site un royaume uni au tonneau qui
renforce son alliance avec son allié
historique les états unis
'cela ne laisse aucun doute c'est que
nos
adversaires
d'économies ce n'est pas très important
pour le peuple et il s'agit d'une
démonstration à l'attention des cachets
du
royaume uni et est les etats unis ont
une relation spéciale que la france
qualifie de relations de facilité de
l'aide state
jeter une mousse
leroy génie venu un vernis
est entre les états unis aient voulu
beaulieu qui a le pouvoir
tous les clichés n'importe qui d'autre
et l'australie c'est un accord en ce
sens est ravis on les états-unis le
royaume-uni c'est la troisième roue mais
nous sommes loyaux
bien sûr je le travaille aussi pour
notre propre incurie
mais il ya le territoire français dans
le pacifique révolue
c'est du marketing
une décision qui est bien plus profond
que cela
en europe apparaît effectivement il ya
un problème de
freins
même si la france joue un rôle très
important par exemple en afrique la
france a en elle même n'a pas un très
gros poids et alain gras espère que la
colère
n'est qu'un simulacre une façade du ritz
oui de ce huis clos à paris
elle est faible
et parce que les autres pays européens
le souhaitera courjault lithiques de
défense commune n'en finira pas
ce sera étrange c'est le lac le calcul
fait à washington comme un autre vous
disiez le royaume uni qui est dans cette
affaire peut-être une forme de deux
troisième roue effectivement la france
ne s'attaque pas vraiment au royaume uni
dans cette affaire
l'union européenne dénonce d'ailleurs ce
soir à l'instant un manque de loyauté
des états unis a dit charles michel mais
elle ne s'adresse jamais allons ça veut
dire quoi c'est une manière de dire
comme le disait l'ambassadeur enclenche
raison tout à leur ex ambassadeur c'est
une quantité négligeable on vous parle
même plus de
foyers mais dans le cadre de cet accord
effectivement la crème sur le gâteau
afin de donner l'impression que cet
accord est le bal respectable pour le
reste du coup il est important d'en
faire partie car cela nous rapproche de
joe biden qui n'était pas du tout un ami
boris johnson donc effectivement c'est
qu'il ne forme d'allégeance à
boris johnson effectivement est un petit
joueur et la france a raison de se
concentrer sur les actions de washington
un tueur mais nous avons ici de tous les
cultes international le plus grand
acteur ce sont les états unis
et la france réussit à mobiliser les
autres acteurs et puis européenne tout
aussi
réussi à développer une politique
autonome alors cela pourrait changer les
équilibres mais pour le non ce n'est pas
le cas
insultant de considérer que londres et
le vagin et végétales mais
tactique c'est une bonne approche
de ce sont les états qui ont pris ces
décisions qui ont décidé d'appuyer
d'asseoir leur contrôle sur la région du
pacifique
en europe le libre des pouvoirs est un
peu vif et rise et voilà pourquoi
autorise-t-on hanson prétend que tout va
bien que la france aujourd'hui on en
parlait il ya un instant un certains
politiques français souhaite mettre sur
la table la question de la participation
de la france au commandement intégré de
l'otan qu'elle serait dans cette affaire
le regarder des royaumes unis sur ce
point sur cette problématique
je suis très de préserver le temps
neuves dans l'union européenne qu'il ne
faut pas
que l'otan en tant que mécanisme de
défense contre les ennemis de l'europe
parfois très proches
les britanniques ne veulent surtout pas
pu miner ce qui reste de l'otan en ce
temps que forces de défense stratégique
européen
s'attaquer à l'otan en europe car cela
aurait on n'a pas tous sur les intérêts
crypto sécuritaire botanique dommage les
français voudraient faire un temps
l'otan ne pas être attaqué
ou est ce la veut pas en question de
temps car le son départ des etats-unis
là aussi c'est une question suaire pour
les américains
le cran longueur tran thi vân 6 et
l'allemagne
sauf si les allemands décident de
soutenir la france
sont trop puissants
pour qu'on puisse les ignorer ou les
contrecarrer
beaucoup
avec nos professeurs de droit européen à
l'université
chill merci à vous